we're hearing from the United States
that the former U.S politician and
broadcaster Jerry Springer has died at
the age of 79 Jerry Springer of course
best known to UK audiences as a staple
of daytime TV in the 90s for his
self-titled show The Jerry Springer Show
it was a groundbreaking show at the time
you may remember people airing their
Grievances and dirty laundry it was the
kind of show where who will have
paternity tests and lie detectors online
it really was groundbreaking staff in
the U.S of course he was also a
politician a former mayor of Cincinnati
and quite the life he led but we're just
hearing that he has died at the age of
79 at his home in Chicago we don't have
too much detail at the moment
um but for those of you who do remember
Jerry Springer you'll know that uh
his life also inspired a musical not so
long ago Jerry Springer the musical uh
he really was uh quite an icon when it
came to television which is taking a
look at some of the information we're
getting now
um
obviously Jerry Springer a former mayor
of Cincinnati he was based in Chicago
that's where that U.S TV show The Jerry
Springer Show was broadcast from in
front of live TV audiences uh in the
subsequent years it spawned a number of
CopyCats in the UK and worldwide the TV
show The Jerry Springer Show one of the
most syndicated shows in TV history and
as I said former politician and
broadcaster he led quite the life but
we're hearing this afternoon that he has
died at the age of 79 at his home in
Chicago